high inflation is not only squeezing
family budgets across america it's also
hitting school cafeterias that's right
supply chain disruptions and the rising
cost of food are shrinking what's on the
menu for students scott mcfarland
visited a maryland school to find out
how lunches have changed this year and
what bigger changes and challenges lie
ahead
in the cafeteria at meade middle school
in anne arundel county maryland they
always follow the recipe but this year
they're also learning to improvise
they used to offer five entrees a day
here but now it's down to just one
eighth grader elijah lee has noticed
what many students nationwide are seeing
we had no more condiments like ketchup
and mustard and a ranch which i loved
the shifting and shrinking school lunch
menu
supply chain disruptions and the
spiraling cost of key ingredients has
forced school districts to pull back or
make substitutions
at some schools no more hamburgers or
chicken patty sandwiches due to problems
and the price of buying buns and ketchup
instead at this school they offer more
tacos or bun less options and try to
navigate a shortage of healthy options
like carrot sticks our students are very
savvy they know what they eat what they
want even the trays and plates have been
in short supply plates became
unavailable we had to call those
manufacturers and develop those
relationships to say how do we best get
the trays we need to service our
students a new survey of school
districts nationwide reveals 97
of meal programs reported challenges
with higher costs while 98 acknowledge
problems getting some menu items the
supplies and the ingredients
in one of america's largest school
districts in montgomery county maryland
the local school system has a central
kitchen to cook for all 135 elementary
schools that tray of food i get at lunch
that costs more to make than it did last
year yes significantly
yes we are up about 15
15 sometimes 20 percent in inflation
rates
costs of some ingredients are so
volatile many u.s schools are now making
last-minute changes to the monthly menu
which used to be set in stone so we are
down to weekly menu planning and our
families and even our students and staff
are not used to that costs are poised to
rise again for u.s schools july 1st when
an emergency measure enacted at the
start of the pandemic expires
the u.s department of agriculture which
has been offering schools
4.56 cents reimbursement for every meal
served will reduce that reimbursement to
pre-pandemic levels closer to four
dollars we could be losing about seven
hundred thousand dollars a month in
reimbursement and that's huge
you know that's going to be a big hit
for us
there are proposals here in washington
to extend those higher reimbursement
rates to help schools weather this storm
when we were in nearby montgomery county
maryland we saw them taste testing
vegan sauces and vegan soups for schools
those items are actually easier to
procure right now nate the schools are
navigating trickier menus and tighter
budgets
that's right scott we appreciate you got
to help these kids learn
full stomach does help that's for sure
learn on an empty stomach
all these years later my options were
tater tots and fish sticks yeah
you and me both